[Music]
welcome back to another amazing episode
of the careful boys and today we got
alex in the seat right here oh wow alex
good to be back oh wow he's here what's
up man how are you doing dude pretty
good feeling good i just came off of uh
my covid recovery oh [ __ ] how did you
enjoy it
yeah well how are you going to book him
not let us know man you gotta
no
it was like two and a half weeks ago i
was i started testing negative oh two
and a half hours over two and a half
weeks
was it the was that was it the ohmyan
version
i was telling bart i was dancing in the
rain issues
i heard that's one of the symptoms of
omarion you know anthony what's that a
marion like type move like what's
something you could just do right now
that's like all right i could have been
part of the team that day i'm telling
you i was like
coughing
yeah yeah
get that ice box man he does this a lot
too he'd be doing the
review
like all four you have the like exact
same library with like five dance moves
like this one
the dice we do shaking the dice i do
never mind you know you're already
innovating what's this thing the
wheelchair cat daddy yeah wow
oh man changing your back damn i love
the jerk i can do this let me see the
joker
like real life let me see let me see a
joke real live right now you're a jerk
okay
that's the reject jabberwocky
that's not the jerk
that's the reject oh [ __ ]
so how do you do it then what's the
difference between a reject and a jerk
well it's backwards they're just
different moves and it's shuffling
shuffling yeah like the reject
reach i guess i guess if if you're going
like this it's almost like you're you're
getting rejected so there's like this
opposition feeling okay whereas like
that jerk has like a totally different
grip to it
we're getting lessons though
i can do that too but he's over 200
pounds
during the holidays uh yeah ruin your
holidays yeah so i got it on christmas i
think so i was at my mom's house merry
christmas christmas party family coveted
spread party i gave it to my little
sister my mom my stepdad didn't get it
i'm gonna hit you pretty hard or because
he's a step dad yeah exactly yeah you
don't matter i'm shocked
[Laughter]
saturday i felt fine and then sunday i
like went to work i felt good and then
like towards the middle of the day i
started feeling like a little weaker i
was like oh like if i squeeze really
hard i'd probably pass out or something
like that
got home i was sitting playing video
games and then i started just getting
like a little like weaker and started
feeling like a little clammy you're
squeezing the buttons too yeah and then
so i was like i'm gonna go to sleep so i
started laying down and then i started
getting cold
and i was like damn i'm like i'm getting
really cold so like i stood up and my
fan blew wind on me and it sent me like
in a shiver like attack i couldn't
i couldn't stop shaking so i put on a
sweater sweatpants that's the best sound
effect
i was under covers and i just couldn't
stop shaking do you live by yourself uh
i i rent a room out of a house so
technically yeah cause i don't know
anybody you make any noises where the
other people like what the hell is going
on in there well i have a big-ass fan
going on and [ __ ] so they can't hear
anything but i was like shaking
uncontrollably like i was like laughing
and then a headache came my eyes started
hurting and then i started coughing
uh did you lose taste no i didn't oh
this is not the delta yeah i didn't lose
taste i didn't lose smell
um fell asleep i woke up the next
morning and felt fine i was just
congested for like a whole like maybe a
week and a half like the worst
congestion i've ever had before so
other than that i felt fine i got tested
on monday at kaiser and it took him all
the way till saturday to give me back my
results
pcr be taking like five to seven days
yeah
but why me feeling like i was like oh
that must have just been like
an allergy attack or something so i was
kind of just like i went to work on
tuesday because then my boss was like oh
do you feel good i'm like i feel
perfectly fine like so i went to work
tuesday wore my mask the whole time just
to be safe
all the way up till friday and i was
like dang i still haven't got this test
back let me just go take a rapid test so
i paid a paid for a rapid test and it
was like positive i could have gave you
something for free bro
you should have banged my line i didn't
know [ __ ] yeah bank is lying next time
hey
uh everybody knows i'm the kovit plug so
that one came back positive
then the pcr came back the next day and
it was positive but i really only had
like one hard night to be straight up so
you went to work for a week with coven
kind of do one of those huh
alex is a coped [ __ ] spreader
the new one like i said when i got to
work just to be safe i was wearing my
mask no one at work got it no no one at
my work got it which was cool cool case
study huh yeah it was good
i started testing negative
so i've been negative now for i think
two and a half weeks but jesse the guy
that works with us just got it two days
ago so he's sick now so i think it's
just it's just common right now
you know i work with like i in sales so
i'm seeing a bunch of different people
all the time so i thought i was like at
the at some point i was like it's a
matter of time before i get this
someone's gonna bring it to you yeah it
doesn't aren't medical professionals
asked to come back to work even with
even with omicron yeah you say mask up
and come back but this is this is how
like diseases work or like viruses work
right like
like they don't
people don't know
a lot of people you know we know that we
had like a massive flu like during world
war one it was called the spanish flu
but it wasn't really from spain
originally [ __ ] in the u.s or other
places people don't really know right
because they kept it so [ __ ] secret
right
but that one was so [ __ ] deadly that
like soldiers were getting it during um
you know trench warfare and [ __ ] and
they would drop dead within hours
damn yeah and they would [ __ ] make
people blue like [ __ ] it would be
crazy right but the flu we have today is
because um
the way that they got rid of that was
the the flu mutated
and then um it was able to live but like
it was it has a symbiotic relationship
with human beings where like viruses
they don't want to just destroy a human
being because that's their host they got
to stay alive they want they want to
continue
infecting people
but then if all the population dies then
the virus is like well i basically
[ __ ] myself right it has to mutate to
being milder and then it keeps spreading
i don't know they're that smart [ __ ] but
that's how omicron works bro like
they're just like i'm too strong
that does that i know right because they
they can't go to another host if the
host
but then the weaker ones can keep going
and then they'll overtake because if you
have the weaker version too like you're
immune yeah so so or you're you know
it's like having the antibodies but it's
just that it's like having a vaccine
basically but
this is the this is the crazy part right
is like
the the the omicron it's good
it's it's it's like this we want it to
mutate we want it to be more contagious
we wanted to get weaker
deaths are going down yeah debts are
going down cases are going up right now
but it's continuing
what's your review
how many stars how many stars it was
fine that's just the testing i wish i
would have got my test back sooner so i
didn't have to go to work for a whole
goddamn week i could have took all these
days off the testing was worse than the
symptoms oh yeah no because you blame
kaiser more than omicron yeah bro
there's a there's a omicron there i went
to work for a whole week i got one day
off from kovid but everybody else like
everybody was getting like a whole two
weeks off and [ __ ] i was like imagine
the pcr test during the spanish food
days they're like we're gonna tell you
in seven days and like you're positive
you're already at the casket
but you just had it again uh no no so
here's the [ __ ] funny thing right i i
got sick again uh earlier this week
right and you got sick earlier this week
why did you [ __ ] tell us man [ __ ]
infected this [ __ ]
everyone get some vitamins from here
i specifically didn't tell y'all so i
could give it to you
now uh i got to say earlier this week
but you know because we're in like this
covid generation it's like
every year i get like a cold or the flu
during the season right it's like normal
everybody gets it around me but nowadays
when you get the cold you're like you
gotta [ __ ] like double t you gotta
text everybody you gotta [ __ ] like
take tests and [ __ ] like that and it's
just this huge [ __ ] deal but i tested
negative and
now it's gone and now i'm like oh yeah i
guess you can still just get a regular
cold huh that's still
i was thinking about that like even
maybe just
a few years ago
like let's say someone caught a cold or
something right and like let's say they
still go to the gym they're training
hard or whatever he's got a hoodie on
you're like oh man full of hardcore is
badass or a guy he's like he's back in
construction doing whatever when you're
sick and you like push through it it was
like man that guy's dope everyone's like
yeah yeah but now it's like if someone
has like
what the [ __ ] are you doing here you
[ __ ] crazy
yeah stay your ass at home yeah it's
like whoa it's crazy that the whole
thing just flipped it's like now you're
irresponsible but back then you're like
badass
i kind of like it bro if you're sick
like and you have active symptoms stay
away from me that's i like it too kind
of like this like that
like that's
if you're like coughing a bunch cove it
or not
it's just like i mean i know but you
cough the most out of anybody i've ever
you know i'll tell you
how do i how do i cough
that's because i'm about to throw up
because we're working out so hard that's
what we usually have nick coughs the
most out of you he has workout coughs
before workout coughs sitting down
coughs
eating cars i don't even notice his
coughs
he got okay now i'm gonna check cause
he's gonna not so
he's going to be self-conscious the
whole day i remember when kobe first
came around he was coughing so much
you know what's crazy though
since since uh kobe has been around i'm
in the gym working out i have never
choked on drinking water more than ever
in my life and as soon as i start like
drinking water start coughing everyone
just completely freaks out yeah they
look at you like yeah i don't blame them
i get it i get it because when you hear
it too now you're just like yo what the
well that's the thing like i still i'm
still coughing from it and it's like
weird it's like i'll have to cough like
right now i'm having like a cough but
then like maybe in two hours i'll stop
coughing for like six hours and then it
comes back it's just random times same
type of cough is it like flammy or dry
it's it's dry and it's like an itchy and
non-productive cough too right it
doesn't feel like there's something
that's happening you're just like you
have a cough have you tried honey and
lemon
today's video is brought to you by
babble babble is a language learning app
that sold more than 10 million
subscriptions wow that's a lot of users
that is a lot of users but it's also
helpful that it's an app because you can
have it on phone
if you're trying to go to a new country
and you want to learn a new language
check babel out because it has a lot of
dope features
you know what i uh went during the
summer's times
during the summer times i went to mexico
right and i was like man
i wish i knew spanish like just being in
la you listen to it a lot right and
you're just like oh i could pick up so
much but now with babel i can learn
spanish on the go pretty quick 15 minute
lessons right right and next
that means mr stomach that was the name
of my friend yeah mr stomach it's really
quick on the go and i thought it would
be pretty cool like it's like we're kind
of on lockdown anyway yeah so i'm just
gonna use this time to learn more
spanish so that when i do go back i'm
gonna be like espanol all day homie yeah
it's dope i like that babel
is created with ai with language experts
over a hundred of them so then that way
what you're learning is actually very
practical and they also have speech
recognition technology so it helps with
enunciation and accent so you're not
just saying it like the wrong way also
their teaching method has been
scientifically proven to be effective so
it's not just someone coming in here and
being like yeah here's some flash cards
or whatever here you just memorize some
words right they actually use language
experts to develop this program and it's
pretty awesome and one of the other
awesome things about babel is they have
a 20-day money-back guarantee so you can
try it out for a week or even two weeks
and if you don't like it you get all
your money back and also they have 14
different languages you could choose
from from like german
french espanola it's pretty awesome
and right now they have a sick ass deal
for our fans only go to babel.com be a
off the record and when you get three
months you get another three months for
free that's six months for the price of
three go to babel.com off the record to
get this special deal and learn some new
languages i've tried honey actually i
have one i haven't i have a honey bottle
like this right on my bed
so i'll take it just try pressing your
thumb for 10 seconds
actually it's gone you guys see how um
in the uk i think it's boris johnson who
was making all the uh the new mandates
and it's all open bro he's lifting it
all he lifted it all and and you see
everybody who's [ __ ] in that uh in
the congress room and [ __ ] like that
just being like
celebrating every announcement he's like
no more mandates it's up to the the good
judgment of the british people you know
what i mean i kind of like that man
just lift it and let everyone make their
own decisions if you want to stay inside
stay inside if you want to go make out
with covet patients go make out
what sucks with that is that
people are saying boris is only doing it
because he got caught with controversy
like he was at a party
and then like it was during lockdown but
the thing is real reason people don't
know that the uk was already open that's
hilarious they were open several months
ago and then they had to do shut back
down shut back down but then the the the
citizens on ground they were like [ __ ]
no so no one was following it so then
the world thinks like oh uk was on
lockdown but they're like nah they've
been def like you know defiant toward
their government and apparently john
boris johnson wanted to be like i think
it was sweden who was just like nah i
heard immunity but then like just you
know politics eventually i think the
people will just not have the mandate
anymore like even now
before like you would go in like a
restaurant or whatever and they're like
you have to go back and get it now like
i'm like oh [ __ ] i'm just like wait
that's fine so i just look around so i
think even the people themselves are
just
people starting to care less i've seen
um remember we're playing [ __ ] at the
uh chin diapers circus circus where were
we playing roulette oh yeah and the
foreman
had it like this the whole time
yeah
and he was asking us to put our masks
together the funniest was that there was
that other dude on the side who kept
dropping it down and the guy would be
like yo put it back up he told him three
times and then the dude started winning
and the guy was like that's fine
see it's just gonna loosen up by itself
like i don't mind
i honestly just hate wearing it at the
gym that is the worst for me like going
to the store and [ __ ] whatever but the
gym i'm just like man i'm getting so
sick of that [ __ ] you know what's crazy
though is like
the way how people reacted like
politically just like emotionally
everything like i wanted to have this
conversation in 2020 [ __ ] march
but it was so
dangerous to openly talk about how you
feel about covet and everything just
explore an idea emotionally charged it's
not like you know it's like wait i
thought we lived in a democracy where we
can kind of challenge our authority and
i thought science is when you challenge
the belief or just the the you have to
you know see and and you have to get
proof and i don't know i was like why do
you just listen to authority like if
march 2020 was a western movie and
someone was like hey what do you guys
think about the mass but would you say
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you and it's like you
can't even just have a regular
conversation yeah if she is a mexican
standoff yeah there's no reason it's
just something there's a mexican
someone's just posting
i'm not a doctor i'm just a [ __ ]
goofball that talks about getting rim
jobs on youtube like why am i a threat
why people kind of makes you a doctor
right
kind of a threat also because people are
like oh you you're pretty tired there's
so many people watching you you have
such a you know you have to like set a
good [ __ ] role model i'm like i never
did that in my whole entire
entertainment career from the [ __ ]
start yeah right so why do i have to
start now
your science news from us yo i know
right the [ __ ]
that's what blows my mind we're learning
what viruses are uh to be fair that uh
just kidding films plaque says teaching
good things in a bad way so you are
teaching we are teaching good things
that's subjective bro okay so i'm
staying true to you know what jk's
always been
well we teach other things like
friendship
and harmony with others that's what we
teach right that's pretty good teach
that yeah dude through conversation
through you know hanging with an
indirect lesson right i guess seeing
tweets seeing tweets nowadays talking
about how you know everybody was like a
couple days ago signing up for the usps
like four [ __ ] copy testing you get
for free and [ __ ] right everybody my
family's texting me about it like my
co-workers and stephen it's like you
signed up for this right sounds like a
pair i'm looking at tweets about it and
[ __ ] where it's like oh next time
pandemic rolls around maybe we don't
have to wait three years before we get
free tests see that's the thing too all
right yeah we're all
where's the advancements in the testing
i feel like it's like some states in the
midwest or wherever they don't have
testing sites like they can't go get
tested within within like a couple hours
of them feeling sick or anything so it's
just like it's going this is my test
oh geez
people are hardcore it's crazy
i'm negative
they're
someone from the playing confirm or deny
this russian roulette's your test has
anyone ever actually scanned your your
uh qr when you showed it
it's happened to me once when i went to
a concert oh and they scanned it yeah
they actually scanned it oh they skimmed
like you're on your backspace yeah
because i have it on like on my apple
wallet
and they they actually like they were
only in hawaii yeah hawaii is pretty
strict because um i got you know
vaccinated and everything and had to do
all that because hawaii's getting so
expensive to do the test every single
time
and then um over there you gotta have
the records to go eat at a restaurant
yeah yeah yeah yeah and then a lot of
places they'll you know they'll check
when was the last time you got it
whatever they're pretty thorough so
that's just different state by state you
know but it makes sense out there like
they don't have enough hospital beds
yeah so if all of a sudden the locals
get sick and all the tourists get sick
like they don't even have like tents to
set up to deal with people that are sick
so yeah but they got beaches and stuff
so you know that's kind of a nice place
to be seen yeah be in the warm sand
this is my cover treatment it's like
dude you're sick you need rest and
relaxation
have you seen people starting to
vaccinate their dogs and stuff
they vaccinate their dogs yeah there's
some people with that you can hate the
dogs
covet dogs i don't know i think people
that's crazy man just worried about you
know why couldn't this just be as simple
as like hey
uh
this is the scientific evidence yeah
okay never dude and then this is how
we're still figuring it out because it's
new because the the paper that's printed
has the pharmaceutical company right
because it's like yo this is evidence
this is new this is a this is a [ __ ]
we have all these universities that
aren't like funding this science by
pfizer or whatever
we just want
the people to be healthy and and so they
can go back to you know living life and
all that [ __ ] but they're so [ __ ]
politicized there's so many different
people that are like nah if you're on
the left you got to do it this way if
you're on the right you got to do it
this way it's like what the [ __ ] that's
that's what sucks the most out of all of
this you see the uh the conspiracy that
uh bob saget died because of the booster
are you serious are you serious did they
say he died from a heart attack that's
that was that his cause of death i don't
even i don't even know well you know
what was weird about that is like just
the day before he finished up a stand-up
show and i was on his instagram i was
like what the [ __ ]
i'm looking at a ghost bro he performed
live and then just died the next day
yeah he was out there for a whole
weekend to do shows i believe r.i.p dude
yeah
and i thought like trying to he's a rock
star it's an overdose or whatever but
but yeah i don't know because he said he
didn't have any health issues right
wow heart disease is a silent killer i
think
well the booster uh like apparently he
was like on a another like podcaster
radio show like a week prior and he's
like oh yeah i just got the booster i'm
about to do some shows and stuff like
that and then again there's no physical
ailments or anything
i had a friend
of a friend who was talking about how
like when she got the uh the booster
what they don't tell you is that like
you can [ __ ] with your like in your
menstrual cycle
what and yeah so it's like you know
you'd have you like your period yeah and
then suddenly you get the booster the
next thing you know you have a heavy
period for another week like right after
which is uncommon for your menstrual
cycle so it's kind of like there there
are effects that happen to your body
you know what i mean but like nobody
nobody tells you what the side effects
are in the booster
well i don't want what was in the first
vaccine i don't know i got the ac like
the good the actual booster i got the
actual antibodies what the [ __ ] is that
oh
you mean you got sick so i'm fully
vaccinated and i got the oh
and then i got the delta and then i got
the booster and then you got the omicron
super saiyan
i don't know if i'm gonna go get the
next booster like i'm done you got two
in the next three years you know what i
mean that's the crazy [ __ ] too do you
remember when they said that when you
get vaccine like vaccinated you won't
get sick that's what i thought the
beginning and they found out and then
people were still getting sick and
people were still spreading the disease
and it's like the [ __ ] dude like this is
the kind of [ __ ] that i think gets
people to
you know they can't trust the government
anymore because it's like well you're
telling me all this [ __ ] and then and
then you're not even like backtracking
or fixing what you said and people are
still like being duped so it's like what
the [ __ ] not everybody's playing by the
same rules
that's true
what the hell did i take it to old
school and just make ginger dude ginger
ginger tea
honey
brown sugar and reference i'm like yeah
he's like
ginger old school
you know [ __ ] just get the [ __ ]
dude
i think that'll help
tai chi in the park not to scare you
guys but um
the creator of this vaccine one of the
guys that were a part of the research
team that developed this
i think it was like in the 90s or
whatever um
he
is actually one of the biggest skeptics
and speakers of like why we shouldn't be
rolling this out and why we shouldn't be
taking it he was he did like a three
hour interview on joe rogan um
one of the most important parts of this
is i forgot his name so it's gonna be
pretty something but i did see or i did
see what you're talking about
or something about graham cochran
you're close johnny cochran something
like that carl malone utah jazz
moses malone against the vaccine
but
let's see how that flow overlaps like
wait what happened he just gets catholic
you start the headline
yeah it's crazy especially from the guy
that was a part of the research team and
the development of this vaccine level
aren't people trying to discredit him
yeah
but he lays out why they keep blocking
him on like twitter which is like yeah
sometimes you can't like uh
i don't know i don't agree with
everything that guy says but as far as
trying to censor him on these platforms
it makes him it makes him seem even more
real exactly like it makes it a whole if
somebody's spreading misinformation you
like give the real information but if
somebody's spending
telling the truth that's like you know
detrimental to like the government
narrative you like censor them yeah yeah
but he also cites
who's trying to discredit him the
reasons why and also he ha it's like his
reasons aren't like oh they're trying to
get me because the government
it's it makes sense it's like money
motivated
and he breaks it down and he even talks
about who the writers were that try to
discredit them and how it's all tied
together so it's not like one of like
he's an intelligent human being like and
he's very very good looking yeah
[Laughter]
oh my bad i thought that's what you're
gonna say
[Music]
[Music]
bye
[Music]